Hello, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Sanjay Sarma.
I'm Professor of Mechanical
Engineering at MIT,
and I'm also the Vice
President for Open Learning.
What a wonderful
gathering this is.
This is really
siblings and cousins
and brothers and sisters in
the open education movement.
Knowledge is like oxygen. I
hope no one figures out how
to charge for oxygen.
I hope they figure out
a way in which we never
charge for knowledge.
It should be like the air.
We should breathe it.
We are at a very
interesting point in time.
MIT faculty speaking
for my own colleagues
have an opportunity to
learn from senior leaders
at HBCUs, who are
promoting education
equity by spearheading OER,
open education resources
within their institutions.
And we are looking at MIT to
include culturally relevant
materials in our own courses.
This effort is an invaluable
resource for discovering more
a more inclusive canon of OER.
The hope really is that
my colleagues adapt
these OER materials created
by HBCUs and colleagues
in our own courses here,
and then we share them back
with the world through
OpenCourseWare.
And so this way,
we can collectively
promote educational equity, not
only within our MIT community,
but in the nation,
and perhaps the world.
The question really for us today
is, how can we do this today?
How can we do this together?
And this is just the
first conversation.
How do we establish a metabolism
of open educational resources,
especially around
equity and around,
in this particular case,
for our discussion,
around materials that
are culturally relevant.
So I would like to
particularly thank
two colleagues, Robbie
Melton and Gerry
Hanley for doing
this great event,
and the amazing panelists.
And I welcome you to this.
And with that, I'll hand off
to my friend and colleague,
Curt Newton from MIT.
Thank you, Sanjay.
Just a couple of housekeeping
notes before we dive in.
We're going to try to use
the chat collectively,
in the spirit of conversation.
As we're going, please enter
your questions in the chat,
and I'll encourage
our presenters here
to engage, and feel free to
answer directly as we're going.
We are recording.
And as we get into
the Q&A at the end,
if you don't want to
appear in the video,
I suggest that you keep
your video turned off.
I'd like to thank, along with
all of our participants here
today who have joined us, also
thank the Hewlett Foundation
for facilitating this
introduction between MIT Open
Learning and these HBCU
leaders, and to our colleagues
across the Open 2030 working
group for the inspiration
over the past couple of years.
And again, just reiterating
Sanjay's closing remark,
we hope that this is the
first of what will be many,
many ongoing conversations.
And with that, I'd like to
hand over to Dr. Robbie Melton.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Robbie Melton.
And today, we are going to
help history in the making.
Again, I'm Robbie Melton.
On behalf of the
Historically Black Colleges
and University and
Tennessee State University,
we are here to share our
passion, our purpose.
But today, we are all,
colleagues, will make history.
I already had a
presentation for you,
and you will see by my slides.
But I'm going to go
off script on purpose.
Ladies and gentlemen, on behalf
of all educators in the world,
we all are in a war.
Today we're not going to just
talk about open education.
We're going to do
something about it
on behalf of the
people of Ukraine,
who are now leaving their
homes, leaving their schools,
leaving their history.
Today, we're going to
share with you why we
have the cultural collection.
We are here to
demonstrate, all of us,
what we can do with the
mighty tool of technology.
Today as we present
and share with you
the purpose of a
cultural collection,
not only for the HBCU,
but for the world,
we dedicate this presentation to
those diversity inclusive, all
of those words that we hear.
Today we're going to
do something about it.
So I have my team
already in the chat.
And as we go through
this presentation,
this is what we're going to do.
We are going to capture
the culture of the Ukraine,
as they try to take it away,
with open education, which
means open to everyone.
I'm going to have you, because
you know how to multitask,
while you're at
your computer, I'm
going to have you to find
on the internet history,
famous people, whatever
about the Ukraine,
and you're going to put
that URL in the chat.
My team will capture
that URL highlighting
the Ukraine and
their contribution
to education, because by the
time you wake up tomorrow
morning, we will have a
cultural collection on behalf
of the Ukrainian people.
They will not lose their
history, nor their education.
All of you should celebrate
on behalf of the Hewlett
Foundation why a
cultural collection
is so vital to open education.
And with that, we are
all now responsible,
because we have the
tool of technology
to help underserved population,
and we're going to do it today.
So with that,
everyone, I'm going
to go through my presentation,
but you have homework to do.
While you're at that
computer listening,
I need for you to
start searching.
Get on Google.
Get on those search engine,
and find information
about the Ukraine,
so that we can put it
in a special collection.
That's what we can do together.
So with that, I will
start my presentation.
But we are here
again for a purpose.
The purpose of the
cultural collection
for the HBCU, the same as every
other underserved population.
It is to bring to the world our
contribution, our achievement,
and to share, share, share.
So with that, on behalf
of the 106 HBCU sisters,
we come to you with a
curation of our history,
our achievement, how about our
distinguished faculty members.
So as we roll this
away, we again,
can change this whole world.
And we can do
something about it.
So with that, again,
the next slide
we'll share with you,
our cultural collection,
and our underlying
purpose right now.
Everybody, students cannot learn
from books they can't afford.
We all know that.
And unfortunately,
in our day, people
are trying to restrict books.
They're trying to destroy books.
We together, all 75 of us,
can make sure we have access
to education and books.
Next slide, please.
So with that, everyone, you
all know the cost of textbooks,
here are some old
numbers, because inflation
already jumped up the
price of textbooks.
Right now, the
average cost $1,200.
You might think, wow, that's OK.
No, it's not OK.
Again, students cannot learn
from books they cannot afford.
Next slide.
So with that, let me just share
with you the impact of textbook
costs on students.
Again, you see the statistics.
Some take fewer courses.
Some don't even register
for a specific course,
or how about you just
drop out or withdraw.
Here's the one that
you should center on.
Earned a poor grade
because I could not
afford to buy the textbook.
Fail a course because
I couldn't afford.
Or guess what, everyone?
You don't purchase the
required book at all.
Open education.
That's what we are here for.
But within open education,
next slide, please,
we missed a little component.
And so we were able
to conduct, hot off
the press, a faculty and
students survey report.
And OK, you all know.
We know that we
need to inform more.
We need to contribute more.
But guess what else we found?
We found, next slide, that we
were missing a whole component
of cultural selection.
Our students, our faculty,
our communities kept saying,
thank you for open education,
thank you for a free textbook,
thank you for affordable
learning solution.
However, next slide,
please, you will
see that they also found
that they didn't find
culturally relevant materials.
Look at the numbers.
This should say something.
Again, we have in our hands
the tools, the knowledge
to do something about this.
So on behalf of the
HBCU, guess what?
We formed through a partnership
with MERLOT, MERLOT.org--
all right, everybody put
MERLOT.org right there.
Because Gerry Hanley, who you're
going to hear in a few minutes,
stepped up with his open
education portal, to say let's
do something about it.
So that's why you are here.
We're here to share with you
not what we're going to do,
quote unquote.
We're here to share with
you what we have completed.
The next slide
we'll share with you
on behalf of the support from
the William and Flora Hewlett
Foundation.
And yes, I'm going to call out
Angela, yes, Angela B. Barger.
She-- listen, the Hewlett
Foundation said there's a need.
And ladies and
gentlemen, I'm here
to present to you with a
panel, a distinguished panel,
and now with the
partnership of MIT,
that we are able to curate,
highlight, showcase, and give
you just a little taste of
our HBCU cultural collection.
Next slide.
Thank you.
So on behalf, again, of
the historically Black
college and University, you must
be asking, again, the purpose.
The purpose, you're going
to learn something today.
Number two, you're going
to do something today.
Number three, on
behalf of the HBCU,
as we celebrate all cultures.
Next slide.
So I am pleased to share
with you, I need a drum roll,
that our cultural
collection includes
not just general information,
biography, Black History Month,
HBCU history, but we are able
to address diversity, equity,
inclusiveness, all within
this open education portal.
Again, access from all over the
world that any time, any place,
any type of whatever that
can hook up to that internet,
you have this rich resource
right there at your
[INAUDIBLE].
So with that, with our cultural
collection-- next slide,
please--
I'm here to highlight
again our need.
And guess what?
They're going to put it
in the chat, right now.
Because you can go
to it right now.
And again, just think.
You all logged on only
eight minutes ago,
and now you have the richness
of the HBCU community
right there for you.
Next slide, please.
So on a partnership.
That's what all of this about.
Curt and MIT, we're
talking relationship,
partnership, sharing.
Where on behalf of
the National Museum
of African-American
History and Culture,
we already have
curated for you, where
you don't even have
to search and dig
and all that deep diving.
No.
We want it up front and center.
We have curated
for you, on behalf
of the HBC, anything you can
think of regarding our history
and contribution.
Next slide, please.
And as you view this, we
now want to talk about
how do we get the word out?
How do we expand?
Everyone, we have a motto.
So it's not just, oh,
we're going to inform,
or we're going to be strategic.
We are piloting what we call
our OER campus implementation.
We know it has to start and
be supported from the top.
But we have to talk
about sustainability.
We have to talk about how
do you engage your faculty.
And beyond that, we're
talking community here.
We're talking the world.
How do we get it out?
So we include, as you
see, an adoption plan
that starts with the college.
Who?
Everyone, we're talking
about the college chair
to the faculty.
And the next slide
will share with you
we thought if we
could have two or more
from a department to
engage, to create, to remix,
to redistribute all of OER
materials, we would see impact.
And ladies and gentlemen,
I'm here to share with you,
we have impact.
That's why we're
here today to share.
So you see our
deployment finding,
how we started with
campus awareness, faculty
training, course redesign, and
pilot, as well as research.
Next slide.
And now I'm here to share
with you, in a few minutes,
you're going to hear
from our regional hubs.
We know that touch and
technology must go together.
Our regional hubs are able
to touch other affiliates
within our HBCU family.
And boy, wait till you
see in a few seconds what
they have to share.
So with that next slide,
again with the help of MERLOT,
www.merlot.org, yes,
you can drink it too.
I want you to on behalf
of higher education,
not just for the HBCU,
but for the whole world.
We are global.
We have communities
in all disciplines.
And we have peer review.
But Gerry Hanley, I would
like to bring him on.
But again, you
should be searching.
We're going to do something
about that cultural collection
for the Ukraine.
Gerry Hanley.
Hello, everyone.
Gerry Hanley here from MERLOT
SkillsCommons, and California
State University Long Beach.
And I just want
to say, it's just
a pleasure to be a partner
with so many of the friends
here within our HBCUs.
And just going to say a few
quick things about what MERLOT
brings to the table
in partnership
to really pursue the
passions and the purposes
that Robbie has outlined.
So the first thing, I
think one of the things,
is as Robbie laid out, you
need an institutional strategy
in order to really bring a
community of people together.
Because only together
can you really
solve some of these very
challenging problems,
and when we bring the
affordable learning solutions,
so we begin with what is
the learning solutions that
will enable our students
to be successful,
and our faculty to
teach their discipline,
then how do you
make it affordable?
And that has been
a critical element.
And for over 10 years, MERLOT
has been working on this,
and with a grateful support
from the Hewlett Foundation
over the many years
of doing this,
we begin to customize
these programs
to fit into the unique campus
cultures of each institution.
And I think, as
Robbie pointed out
around building the
collection, well, this
is where the technical
infrastructure, where
Robbie and her colleagues
at the HBCU say, Gerry,
we need a bookshelf for
Black History Month.
Well, it's easy to put that
metadata structure in there,
create customized portals,
and within the last six months
over 500 new materials were
created and contributed
into the MERLOT's Africana
culture collection.
And then finally, an
important capability
in order for each of us to
create inclusive strategies
of content and
pedagogical strategies
that you have to enable the
remixing and the revising
of content so it can be
aligned with your local needs
of your students and your
faculty and your community.
And that's one of
the powers of OER,
is that it's in
enabling that process,
and by working with
both open source
applications and
commercial providers
to enable that
remixing and revising
is going to be very important
in order to close the equity
gaps that are so pervasive
in education, both in the US
and around the world.
So with that, I'm
going to pass it off
back to the Tennessee
State University National
Hub, who has been just
amazing in their leadership.
So back to you.
And I welcome the Tennessee Hub.
The Tennessee Hub, serving
as that hub for the HBCUs
with the cultural collection.
I bring on the Tennessee Hub.
Hello everyone.
And I am Dr. Deborah
Chisholm executive director
at Tennessee State
University for OER.
I also have with me my
two colleagues Dr. Ampadu,
and Dr. Hassell, who
will introduce themselves
after I finish presenting.
Next slide, please.
TSU HBCU, affordable
learning solutions.
The Tennessee State University
is the National Hub.
Coordination of
HBCU OER training,
HBCU OER faculty
and student survey,
coordination of
HBCU OER webinars,
HBCU OER library
resources, coordination
of HBCU OER pilots.
And coordination of the
cultural collection as well.
Next slide, please.
Did you know, at Tennessee
State University,
we have 33 OER pilot
faculty members.
We also have 14 departments, two
faculty members per department,
and 17 OER campus
webinars for 2021.
Next slide, please.
Our impact at Tennessee State
University, a student savings
of $81,000 this
past fall semester
with just 33 faculty members
using the free OER materials.
And now I'll pass
it to Dr. Ampadu.
Dr. Ampadu.
Thank you so much, Dr. Chisholm.
Hello, my name is
Dr. Ampadu-Moss.
I am the director of HBCU OER
here at the great Tennessee
State University.
We help coordinate HBCU OER
webinars, HBCU OER surveys,
academic communities,
and OER faculty outreach.
Next slide.
When we help our
faculty members,
we are able to
allow them to come
to an amazing portal, where they
can go to the TSU Excel for Ed
and find OER materials.
We can showcase our
faculty members.
We can have academic
communities,
will have accessibility
for the faculty
members and their students.
We find other OER
resources that are readily
available with different
strategies and tips they
can use in the
classroom, and then,
of course, the HBCU pilots
that we do every semester.
Now with one of
our pilot studies,
our faculty members,
their responses for 2021.
They stated that there
is a need for training
on the use of the Creative
Commons licensing,
that there is an
increase-- there
needs to be an increase
of cultural collections.
There is a need for updated
discipline related OER
materials.
And there is a need for
faculty training regarding
the creation of OER materials.
So after we gather that
information, we said, OK,
what are we going to do?
We decided to have
webinars every Tuesday
at 3:30, where the faculty
members can go ahead and click
on, so we can help fill the
gap and fill all the needs
of the faculty members.
And now, I want to go ahead and
pass it on to the amazing Dr.
Robert Hassell.
Thank you, Dr. Ampadu.
I am Dr. Robert Hassell, TSU
learning support staff here
for writing, and the OER Student
Success Consultant Coordinator
here at Tennessee
State University.
Next slide, please.
We decided to poll
all of the students,
and we got feedback
from surveys,
and they gave us the following
recommendations concerning
our student population.
That there was a need for
OER awareness and benefits
among the students, and there
is a need for on-hand workshops,
and the need for culturally
related materials.
And this response
indicated that there
was a need for more information
in their particular disciplines
of study.
Next slide, please.
One of the most
phenomenal things
we were able to do here at
Tennessee State University
is create an open educational
resource student success coach
at TSU.
We also established
our own bibliography
of TSU current students,
staff, and alumni,
which we are proud to give
you a glimpse of today.
Here's a recap of
our amazing alumni
here in the land of golden
sunshine at Tennessee State
University.
Dr. Glenda Baskin Glover, who
is our eighth institutional
president, and the
first woman president.
She is the International
President of Alpha Kappa Alpha
Sorority Incorporated.
Next we have the
amazing Ed Temple.
And Ed temple has
struggled so hard
to get 43 TSU Olympians to
the Olympics every year.
Oprah Winfrey is a talk
show host, philanthropist,
and notable alumni of
Tennessee State University.
She is best known for the
Oprah Winfrey Show, broadcast
in Chicago, which is the
highest rated television
program of its kind in history.
And then we have the
great Jesse Russell Sr.,
who if you pick up
your phone, and you
see that little triangle that
says data, he created that.
He patented that.
And he was also the
first African-American
to be hired by AT&T.
Thank you so much.
Now we'll pass along
to our partners.
And yes.
And I have my phone right here.
So again, audience,
just to give you
a little taste of the purpose
of the cultural collection.
So we'll start with our partner
institution, Central State.
On behalf of President Thomas
and Ms. Dr. Arlene McSwain,
I'm here to share with
you on their behalf,
with open education
resources, and this support,
I'm pleased to share with you
they have not only courses,
but they have certificate and
degree program using 100% OER.
Ladies and gentlemen, that means
that those students are ready
the first day, first minute
of class, because what?
Open education resources
already in hand.
So again, that's Central
State, as established
by Dr. Arletha McSwain.
Our next partner
coming up I would
like to introduce to
you will be Southern
University at Shreveport.
It is my pleasure to introduce
to you Dr. Veronica McEachin.
And she's going to let
you know how they pulled
the whole department together.
Take it away.
Greetings from Southern
University at Shreveport,
under the leadership of Dr.
Appeaning, Interim Chancellor,
and Dr. Barry Hester, or
Interim Vice Chancellor.
This is a great opportunity
to share some information
with you.
I would like to share some
history briefly with you.
I started helping
faculty members find
open educational
resources in 1999,
before it was actually named,
at Wiley College in Marshall,
Texas.
In 2012, we developed
our online courses
using OER under the
leadership of Dr. Kim Long.
I then moved to Southern
University at Shreveport
in 2014, and started
introducing OER to the campus.
At first, I received a lot
of pushback from the faculty.
However, I developed
a strategy to work
with those that work with
me, and constantly encouraged
other faculty members
to participate.
Dr. Wanda Wiley
recommended that we
focus on developing
general education courses.
After developing the
general education courses
in OER using OER in
2016, this automatically
made most of our
programs OER hybrid,
because we are a two-year
community college.
In 2017, we developed our
second 100% online program
in criminal justice using OER.
The criminal justice
faculty members
decided to use the
OER course materials
in their face to face classes.
All criminal justice students
thought the first day of class
with that course material
ready to be used at no cost.
Moving fast, fast
forwarding to the present,
this opportunity allows Southern
University at Shreveport
to continue developing
the core courses
to build 100%
online program using
open educational resources.
We are currently developing
a 100% online program
in psychology, and
we are developing
courses for our
non-science students
in biology and chemistry.
Our faculty members
that are currently
working in the project, they
are called the design team.
We meet every Monday
for about 30 minutes,
and we're preparing to
present this information
to our entire faculty,
teaching, sharing
with them lessons learned.
So again, we would like to thank
Dr. Robbie Melton, Dr. Gerry
Hanley, and their team for
providing training and support
for our campus, so
that we can continue
developing 100% online
programs using free resources.
Thank you for this opportunity.
And of course, we
thank you so much.
And again, did you hear that?
Criminal justice,
totally online.
Psychology.
And again, anywhere, any
place, anywhere in the world,
you can tap in on those
resources ready for you
right now.
I'm pleased now to share with
you a friend, Jean-Jacques,
again, from Edward
Waters University,
and he's going to give you a
perspective globally where we
are able to make a difference
to a country in need
of open education resources.
Greetings, greetings, everyone.
I cannot even begin to tell you
how happy I am to be here this
morning, or afternoon,
representing Edward Waters
University on this wonderful
open education journey.
I want to thank our two
affiliate institutions,
Lawson State Community, college
and Denmark Technical College
for joining with
us in this effort .
Our main priority is to
make a college education
attainable and accessible to
as many students as possible
through OER, because we
believe that education
is a fundamental human right.
Therefore, we should
not allow anything
to hinder the success of anyone
or any group in their pursuit
of an education.
And that's why we're here today.
Edward Waters University is
distinctively Florida's oldest
independent institution of
higher education, higher
learning, as well as the
state's first institution
established for the education
of African-Americans.
From the beginning, EWU was
faced with both abject poverty
and widespread illiteracy
among its constituents, which
explains why, even today,
90% of our students
are Pell Grant recipients.
Thus, what Dr. Robbie
Melton and Dr. Gerry Hanley
are doing for the HBCU community
as they facilitate access
for our students to open
educational resources
is beyond miraculous.
This is why I'm so excited
to report that our first OER
workshop at EWU, which
was held over a week ago,
was attended by about
90% of the faculty.
Pretty remarkable.
And so our local ARS
team is now motivated
to gather data to add to the
MERLOT's cultural collection,
because we do have
a story to tell.
We are also looking to
extend this opportunity
to developing countries such as
Haiti, where higher education
is literally a luxury.
I should know, because
I'm originally from there.
I remember when I
was in high school,
I had to copy textbook chapters
by hand to prepare for an exam,
and that was on a regular basis.
So I don't have to tell you
that this opportunity would
be like manna from heaven
for the Haitian students.
Thank you, Abby.
Thank you, Gerry.
So what we're
doing in our campus
is making sure that
everybody understands.
My responsibility,
personally, is
to convey this key message to
show our students that we care.
We care for their success.
We care for their education.
And that's why I am so excited
about the level of involvement
of my faculty and the
leadership at the university.
So we are ready.
We are equipped.
And we are thankful for
being on this journey.
Thank you, everybody.
And we thank you.
And again, you see the purpose
for cultural collection.
You see the purpose of
open education resources.
And yet, every day we upload,
we search, just like you all
are doing now for the
Ukraine, so that we
can have a cultural collection
built. At this time,
it is my pleasure to
bring on [INAUDIBLE],,
and you will see for
their graduate program
the impact of open
education resources.
Good afternoon.
Maintaining the spirit of
our founder, Dr. Mary MacLeod
Bethune, Bethune-Cookman
University
allows collaboration to bolster
the infusion of open education
resources in undergraduate
and graduate courses,
not only on our campus in
Daytona Beach, Florida,
but with external partners,
Simmons College of Kentucky,
and Florida A&M University.
Currently, 12 graduate
faculty members
are revamping courses to feature
open education resources,
or function as an
OER only course.
Next slide, please.
A few strategies undertaken
by us to propel forward
include converting all
general education courses
to open education
resources, persuading
six of eight graduate programs
and all graduate programs
offering online degrees
and certificates
to include OER, or fully
convert courses to OER.
Currently, there are more
than 50 faculty members
who have MERLOT accounts.
We continue to recruit
faculty across our partner
universities.
Sharing recordings
that highlight
discipline specific
OER with faculty
is another proven strategy.
And finally, being recognized
for our OER efforts
have all assisted in
moving us forward.
Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen,
did you hear that?
The general Ed Corps, all open
education, graduate programs.
Now you can see together
how we can share.
So with that, I bring
you Morehouse College.
Take it away, Dr. Earl-Lewis.
Good afternoon, and
greetings, colleagues.
I bring you greetings on
behalf of Dr. David A. Thomas,
the 12th president of
Morehouse College Dr. Kendrick
Brown, Provost and Senior Vice
President for Academic Affairs,
and Dr. Clarissa
Myrick-Harris, the Chair
of the Division of Humanities.
This is how our OER program is
anchored at Morehouse College,
and moving forward with our
partners, Claflin University,
Clark Atlanta University, and
our newest partner, Livingstone
College.
I, like Dr.
McEacran, began using
open educational resources
as a response to having
culturally relevant
pedagogical content
as a part of my own
learning, and then,
again, when I became a
member of the faculty
at Florida Memorial University.
Today at Morehouse College, next
slide, please, our key mission,
our key message
is mission driven.
The mission of Morehouse
College is the development
with disciplined minds, who
will lead lives of leadership
and service, with special
responsibility for advancing
knowledge of Black life
history and culture.
So how are we doing OER
at Morehouse College?
We are engaging it in
teaching and learning, faculty
development, and
service learning.
Let me share a few examples.
As a part of the teaching and
learning, 100% of the Africana
Studies faculty and affiliated
faculty within the departments
of English, history,
journalism, religion
and philosophy, cinema,
television, and emerging media,
music, mathematics, computer
science, business and economics
are using affordable
learning solutions.
As a part of our
fall 2021 semester,
we offered 35 sections of our
FYE general education courses.
15 sections of those courses,
the African-American experience
and introduction to
Africana Studies,
representing approximately
45% of the FYE courses
were all OER.
With this in mind, we
estimate that we had
a savings of $2,250 per course.
This resulted in
approximately $33,750
worth of savings for students
during the fall semester
who were enrolled in
our general education
courses, the
African-American Experience.
But students, what
is the impact?
What I am learning,
both anecdotally
and through the data, is that
students remain surprised
that their learning can begin
before the first day of class,
by having access to open
educational resources and tools
to support their learning.
Within our partnerships, as
we are moving with the faculty
development piece, we
have engaged a partner
through A Healing Paradigm,
which is a local wellness
and psychological
services center,
and Dr. Kevin Coakley
at UT Austin, who
created an open source
culturally relevant text
called Making Black Lives
Matter, Confronting Anti-Bias
and Racism.
We're using that text as
a foundational resource
for facilitating understanding,
as well as providing knowledge.
It is well researched,
open source,
and includes the voices of
both undergraduate and graduate
students.
As a part of OER commitment
to service learning,
our [INAUDIBLE] Office
for Community Service
engages OER through the use
of our Apple Initiative.
They engage coding
and creativity
and all of the Apple
learning resources
as a part of their service
learning, in a one-credit lab,
as well as a three-hour course.
They all become Apple teachers,
improve their technology
skills, learn how
to prototype apps,
and do this service
in our communities.
We are excited to continue this
partnership as we move forward,
and our Office of
Academic Affairs
is providing fiscal resources
to support faculty research,
course redesign, and
student internships
to conduct research
utilizing ALS.
So please join us in
visiting the HBCU culture
collection to learn
more about Morehouse
and our esteemed alumni.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
And we thank you so much.
And again, everyone, everyone,
we only got a few more minutes,
OK?
Remember, all that we have
shared is available for you
right now.
So again, they're
going to enter the URL
for the HBCU affordable
learning solution,
and instantly, you
have all that we have.
We're going to conclude
with our network
across all of our
106 sister HBCU.
Take it away, Dr.
Jacqueline McGeHee.
Good afternoon.
My name is Dr.
Jacqueline McGeHee.
I am the library director here
at Arkansas Baptist College
in Little Rock.
But I also consider myself as
part of the TSU, the Tennessee
State, the Tennessee
State University
family, and part of the
HBCU OER librarian curator.
I usually help coordinate
strategies and tips,
and find curated resources for
all of the HBCU librarians,
to help keep OER systems readily
available to your faculty,
to your students, on all
of the HBCU campuses.
And throughout the year, the
best way I've found doing this
is by consistently
staying in discussion
with other fellow
librarians, and finding out
what their strengths and
threats, opportunities
and weaknesses are
on all the campuses,
and using that as
a roadmap to help
other librarians
troubleshoot issues
they may be having
on their campuses.
But several of your
libraries have already
started to receive information
from me on a monthly basis.
And like Dr. Melton said,
like she spoke about,
we are all here to help
distribute information
to one another.
And we just discussed the
OER cultural collection,
which provides a
wealth of information,
from exploring African-American
and Black study
collection and
[INAUDIBLE],, to exploring
free open educational resources
related to African topics,
exploring OER on diversity,
equity, and inclusiveness.
But our initial priority
is to build the OER
cultural collection.
So each month, there
are several of us
who actually post items and
information like you've just
heard to the site.
And Dr. Melton, the
team, and I, we're
all interested in what each
of our schools are doing.
There's a lot of information
that need to be shared.
And this is another way that
is possible for us to do so.
So uploading information to
their website is the key.
It's visible to not just to
HBCU users, but to the world.
And I try to recognize our
strengths and weaknesses
in other schools.
And something that
we'll continue to do
is help meet the needs and to
stay in touch with you all.
We will do our best.
We are available to
help with information
on to the site
about your school,
so if there's anyone that
needs to be highlighted,
anything that's going on that's
very important, please, please,
please try to reach us so we
can get that information out.
But we will also do
the same for you.
So I just want to say thank
you, again, and welcome,
and thank you for having me
as your library OER curator.
And with that, again,
on behalf of the HBCU,
you are able to upload
information, share,
and we just want
to thank, again,
the Hewlett Foundation
for supporting this need.
I have to thank MERLOT
for coming and helping us
to curate, and
MIT, Curt team, we
want to thank you for
allowing us to share
as you are share with us.
So I'm going to
turn it over to Curt
before I say my final
word, because together, we
can do this.
Thank you so much, Robbie.
I'd like to ask, I
know this doesn't quite
work the same way as if we're
all in the same room together,
can we unmute and just applaud.
This is so fantastic
what we've been hearing.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, yes.
I am so energized by the work
that you all have been doing.
And so it's an honor to
just reflect for a moment
here before we get into
the Q&A on what we've been
doing at MIT OpenCourseWare.
So for 20 years, MIT faculty
has been sharing their teaching
materials from a recognition
that we need everyone
everywhere working together
on global challenges,
and we need knowledge
and other tools to do so.
Now, many people come to MIT
for STEM resources, right?
We think we've reached
over half a billion people
around the world.
Students, teachers,
independent learners,
2/3 of whom are coming
from outside North America.
No question, courses
like Learning To Program
are drawing people.
But people are also drawn to the
incredible breadth and richness
of what we're pulling from
across the MIT curriculum.
And this, one of our
most recent publications,
Black Feminist Health Science
Studies, is an example.
Next slide, please.
So OCW at MIT is publishing from
across the entire curriculum,
all departments, all
programs, ranging
from introductory undergraduate
to the most advanced graduate
seminars.
It's really a tremendous
range of topics.
So here on the right, a
couple of other examples.
In addition to learning about
programming, students at MIT
are learning about the social
and ethical responsibilities
of computing, and
we're sharing that
with the world, both for
learners and also resources
for other teachers to
use in their classroom.
We're also sharing, for
instance, videos in the moment.
Down the lower
right, some videos
that we shared from Professor
Amaido for her seminar
on reparations for
slavery and colonization,
which were posted on
our YouTube channel
so that the public could
engage live in this,
as it was happening
in the class,
and those comments could be
fed back into the classroom.
We have voluntary
participation from our faculty.
We think about 60%
have participated.
And we're glad to be able
to have a team of people,
my colleagues on the
OCW team, who then
do the work of converting
those classroom materials,
producing the OER versions
to be shared with the world.
What's in an MIT OCW course?
It's really going to vary
from class to class, depending
on the nature of the subject.
You might find notes.
You might find readings,
documentation of activities,
and assessments.
You'll also find, increasingly,
contributions from students,
because their voice really
matters in this experience.
You'll find more videos
and other rich media.
And also, interviews
with the MIT faculty
about how and why they
teach the way they
do to try to create a dialogue
with other instructors
around the world who are also
getting into open education.
Last slide, please.
So we are excited
later this spring,
very soon to be launching
next generation OCW.
There's a new platform, and
it starts with working really
well on phones, especially
for the many people
around the world for whom
their phone is either
their primary or
only digital device.
Better content discovery
tools, better search
so that people can
find what they're
looking for within that
amazing collection.
But it's not just the
platform and the technology.
We're also making
new investments
in enhancing our
programs to ensure
that the content
that we're bringing
is constantly vibrant and
current and up to date
with what's happening at
OCW, and in particular,
developing and investing
in collaborations
around the open
education ecosystem.
In particular, those that are
centering equity and creating
greater cultural relevance.
We want to see more culturally
relevant OER all the time,
and learning how
to work together
to create and curate
and share this,
so that we can
collectively continue
to take on these pressing
global challenges.
Thank you.
Now I'd like to kind
of pivot and open it
up in our last few
minutes here for some Q&A.
And I'd like to start by
acknowledging just Robbie,
appreciation for being
so sharp and open hearted
about the situation
in Ukraine, and using
our collective capacity
to create this new thing.
Is there any more
you'd like to say
about what's led you to open
this Ukraine project up for us?
Yes, Curt.
Here, this morning, I'm
getting up with the jitters,
and ready to present.
And then I'm
looking at the news,
and I'm seeing and
feeling what's going on.
But I'm here drinking coffee.
And I said, I have
to do something.
We have to do something.
And what can we do?
Number one, we can
capture their culture
and start a cultural curation.
Who knows what's going to
happen with their schools,
with their information.
But right now, we can grab it,
we can upload it, we can start.
Number two, it's about
sharing, because they're
going to need us.
Just like those over in Haiti
and all other across the world,
they need open
education resources.
They don't have books.
But again, we, our collective,
and I'm so proud of you
all again.
I know I was off
script, but I just
thought that, Curt, there was
a need for us to do something
about it.
And I've been watching the chat.
I've been watching my
team upload those URLs.
And ladies and gentlemen,
I am proud to let you know,
we have over 25 entries
for the Ukraine collection.
This is a blessing.
But you can see how, with
the HBCUs, we don't compete.
We complete each other, Curt.
And we did something amazing
today with this webinar.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Thank you, Robbie.
There are a couple of questions
that we got from people
before the event started.
Maybe I'll pose these and
see what ideas people have.
There was a question from Lorita
about any specific information
about what key coursework
is most important right
now in the HBCUs?
What topics or other
characteristics
are you most focused
on right now?
And I'm going to let my
colleague Dr. Monique
Earl-Lewis jump in, because
I think she said it best.
Thank you, Dr. Melton.
We are very concerned
about the assault
on the restrictions
of what individuals
are able to learn these days.
We're very concerned.
We're very concerned about
issues of social justice,
inclusion, and equity.
And at Morehouse
College, we are committed
to making sure that
we are not only
providing a good
education, but developing
leaders for the next
generation and engaging them
in the community.
So through service learning,
culturally relevant pedagogy,
and I'm just so pleased with
the ways in which Dr. Melton
and Gerry Hanley have
advanced this when we first
became a partner in 2018.
We have to have courses that
reflect the lived experiences
of all of our students.
And it is not just
to benefit students
of color,
African-American students.
It's to benefit our white
students, our Asian students,
our Latinx students, who need to
have an inclusive understanding
of the history of this
country and of the world,
because we know identity anchors
our understanding about who
we are, and how we are
to serve and learn.
And so we just look
forward to working
with you and other
members of the community
through course redesign,
engaging technology, looking
at different
learning modalities,
and just bringing our best
game to the table every time.
Yeah.
Any other reflections
on that topic?
Anybody else want to jump in
Thank you, Dr. Earl-Lewis.
There was a question
we got from Rajeed--
I think I'm pronouncing
the name right--
about how we can connect
students in Africa
with students at HBUs, and
what we could all be learning
and teaching from each other.
And maybe start with
Africa, but just
thinking even more
broadly about how
OERs spans geographies
and different cultures.
What experiences
might any of you
have been having to date
around spanning that sort
of different communities?
And again, Curt,
that is the reason
why we have Dr.
Robert Hassell, who
is going to jump in, because
we have a student initiative.
Again, we concentrate,
and we should, on faculty.
But again, our end result
is to help students.
So we now have a student
initiative for OER,
and it is spreading.
Spreading not only between
the HBCU but across the world.
So I'm going to let
Dr. Hassell jump in
and say something about our
student need for open education
resources.
I am so excited about
the student education
and the resources,
because our program
here and our initiative, our
cultural heritage collections
program, it helps
our institutions
meet the complex
challenge of preserving
large and diverse holdings
of humanities materials
for future generations,
by supporting them
in their academic programs
to help them actually access
the benefit of these
research tools,
and develop unique strategies
and approaches to assist them
in constructing their learning
experience as they matriculate.
It is so important
that we make students
aware of the endless
possibilities, not only for OER
to supplement their
learning materials,
but to enhance their overall
experience in the classroom
as well.
Back to you, Dr. Melton.
And back to you.
Because I know we're at
the one minute point.
Let me just say, ladies
and gentlemen, I thank you.
I thank MIT.
I thank the Hewlett Foundation.
And of course, MERLOT.
But my HBCU sisters
and brothers, again, we
were able to bring to you
our passion and our purpose.
And again, yes, it's about
the HBCU for this webinar,
but we're talking about
underserved population.
We're talking about access at
any time, any place, anywhere.
And I want to thank
all of you who helped
contribute to the Ukraine.
Because now you can leave
here and say, I did something.
So again, we thank
you on behalf of HBCU.
Together we complete,
and we definitely share.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, Robbie.
I can't think of anything
else to say to take us out.
That was it.
That was the best.
Just great, great appreciation
for joining us today.
And as I said at
the beginning, we
expect this is the first of
what will be many conversations,
and stay tuned for more of
these in the months and years
to come.
Wish you all--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
And life is good.
Life is good.
Thank you.
Indeed.